ist ja fast schon putzig wie sich jetzt
medien und politiker gegenseitig die
schuld geben für den erfolg der afd
in diesem sinne herzlich willkommen zur
großen wer hat schuld gala mit christian
ehring
[Musik]
wer hat jetzt die chance
wer hat die chance ihr kost mich an
deswegen fragt
die handschuhe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen bei
wer hat schuld
gute frage wer hat schuld hier eher zum
beispiel hat schuld die blöden medien
ich bin die blöden medien ja klar also
symbolisch jetzt die bild -zeitung
beispielsweise hat uns in den wochen vor
der wahl fast täglich den arsch aus der
hose gegruselt mit so viele flüchtlinge
keinen schulabschluss oder burka frau
verprügelt die schuhverkäuferin die
füttern wochenlang wochenlang füttern
die die alte angst maschine und dann
nach der wahl gerichtshofs yahoo
warum sie das alles so ängstlich und
hysterisch das ist aber auch komisch
oder die vier großen sender fragen dem
tv duell eine stunde dann nur nach
flüchtlingsthema und her wäre das muss
ich ihnen leider sagen auch gewisse
satiresendungen haben die afg vielleicht
einen tick zu oft erwähnt gar keine
frage dass geo zu da haben die kollegen
von extra 3 echt scheiße gebaut das muss
man so sagen
jedenfalls ist der erfolg der afg eine
gemeinschaftsproduktion da haben so
viele mitgeholfen facebook twitter und
co
danke nochmal ihr habt es möglich
gemacht dass millionen von deutschen
ungestraft ihren hass ins netz göbel
können und natürlich auch dr angela
merkel die sich zu fein war in rente zu
gehen obwohl dann noch mal in der
uckermark spreewaldgurken einzutippen
wie es sich für eine frau in ihrem
alltag gehört
[Applaus]
irgendjemand auf die vierte amtszeit
verzichtet
das ist ja wahnsinn werde alles schulter
sage ich doch und jetzt kommt's 60
prozent der fdp wähler sagen ich hab dir
nicht aus überzeugung gewählt sondern
weil ich von den anderen parteien so
enttäuscht wenn leute protestwahl ist
schwachsinn glaubt es mir man bestraft
sich immer nur selber ich weiß wovon ich
rede
bei mir war es damals so ich habe mir
extra das arschgeweih stechen lassen um
meine eltern zu schockieren ja natürlich
ja hier so ja total
[Applaus]
natürlich
zu viel information
es war ein reifer meine mutter fand
super hat sie auch so ins stechen lassen
in deutschland haben wir ein parlament
voller rechter machtspiel ist genau
dasselbe aus enttäuschung wunderbar es
ist aber doch sehr persönliche ehre ja
natürlich so viele haben hier scheiße
gebaut und soll ich mal sagen wer
hauptsächlich also wer ganz ursprünglich
schuld ist am afd wahl desaster an
diesem erfolg der afd
es ist dieser mann das tritt nach meiner
kenntnis ist das sofort unverzüglich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kurz danach
damals leider zu illegaler
masseneinwanderung die unsere
freiheitliche kultur komplett zerstörte
hallo die afd wurde auch von westens
gewesen schnauze sie machen mir den weg
nicht kaputt musik
[Musik]
ja die scheiße
ihr kost mich an
ich will nach hause
[Musik]
christian moser
[Applaus]